really really good audience questions
this week and I'm gonna jump right into
them remember any method you want to get
these questions to us I'm glad to take
it reddit Twitter Facebook email YouTube
I don't know whatever works for you
rich wrote in saying how well would you
guys would stand torture what method
would break you the fastest I I don't
know if people will be surprised or this
by not Pat I think many people won't
because they already like to email in
saying I'm a [ __ ] but basically any
method of torture I think would be would
be pretty pretty effective on me I
particularly cringe at at like
fingernail type stuff and like I type
stuff but yeah I I mean I think it would
be pretty damn easy unless I were to
receive extensive training at how to
withstand torture I mean I think the
most effective one Mon me would be
waterboarding oh yeah we are to believe
that waterboarding is in fact torture
yeah because then you just had this idea
that you're going to die any second and
it's it's highly effective yeah I mean I
think I would start to probably have a
panic attack in a suit if I was put in
some super claustrophobic situation
I hate super loud music and noise and I
know that sometimes that's also used
like blasting really aggressive heavy
metal at people to make them
uncomfortable but certainly physical
stuff waterboarding seems horrific and
and just the I don't want to get you
know this is a show that's on 200
broadcast radio and television stations
so I don't want to get too into details
of things I've heard about but you know
you've heard about rats under a bowl
that did there's so many different
things I don't think I'm built to
withstand physical torture I don't know
and and I think many people probably
would would like to think that they'd be
they'd be able to withstand it
my sense is a lot of those people are
just not that well acquainted with what
it would be like they're sort of
thinking of vaguely oh I could do it I
could just would stand it and it really
makes me understand why when John McCain
says when you torture someone you don't
get good information they just say
whatever it is they think you want to
hear to get the torture to stop that
makes a lot of sense to me when I think
of
being tortured and it's a shame too that
we're still using some of these methods
in Guantanamo Bay I mean loud music is
one of them making people stay up all
night four days in a row I mean this is
still going on no doubt about it and I
think there's sort of like the more
gruesome and like Middle Ages types of
torture which are more cartoonish and
caricatures of insane
torture and then there's sort of a lot
of the more modern stuff the
waterboarding the sleep deprivation the
the messing with people psychologically
and that type of thing I don't think I'm
built to withstand any of it if people
in the audience have training and I know
that there are well I don't want to say
too much about who's in the audience but
there are people in the audience who
have experience related to psychological
preparation for these types of things
etc if any of you and you know who you
are want to email in with some thoughts
on how you can be trained I would I'm
genuinely curious about that there was
actually to go back to waterboarding
there was a radio talk-show host
Mancow Muller yeah I can't stand the guy
yeah he went out to prove that
waterboarding wasn't in fact torture yep
and the guy could only last about four
seconds and I remember that he ended up
going back on his claim and it was like
yes this is absolutely a torture method
it was the one time where I thought that
Mancow did something fantastic and he
did say he's like I was completely wrong
this absolutely is torture
send me your thoughts